الشلال الملون هذا عباره عن تلال من
القمامه التي تسكم الانوف وتهدد بانتشار
الامراض والاوبئه في مدينه تعز مدينه كانت
فيما مضى احدى اجمل مدن اليمن اختنا
[موسيقى]
ماشي في الشارع
الحوثي تحاصر المدينه فتمنع الجهات
المحليه والدوليه من تقديم الدعم
والمساعده الامر الذي يهدد باثار كارثيه
على الخدمات الصحيه والبيئيه لمئات الالاف
من السكان
القائمه على مهمه النظافه هي اكثر
كانت اكثر موارده هي محليه من الرسوم
والضرائب من السلطات المحليه كان دعم من
منظمات المانحه التي
انسحبت منذ بدء الصراع في البلد
وبقيت في بعض مناطق لكن نشاطها بقي محدود
الا انها عاده تدريجيا لاسمها في
محافظه عدن اللي هي العاصمه المؤقته حاليا
يسكنوا تعز نحو 600 الف نسمه وتتفاقم
معاناه الاهالي هناك بعد انسحاب جهات
داعمه لصندوق النظافه جراء المخاطر التي
تتعرض لها في ظل الحرب التي يشنها
الحوثيون في اليمن منذ سنوات
وفيما تستمر النفايات بالتراكم امام ابواب
البيوت مسببه الكثير من الامراض وبينها
حمى الضنك يحاول السكان ايجاد حلول بدائيه
لهذه الازمه ربما قدام البيت حقنا لها
اشهر
عامل ثلاثه برامل ابناء صار عندهم اسهالات
طرش
حمى الضلاك انا نفسي اكثر من ثلاث مرات او
بحدود ثلاث مرات هكذا
تكدس النفايات في شوارع تعز وفي سلال
المهملات وكل ما قد ينشا عن هذا من امراض
للجهاز التنفسي لاسيما مع انتشار البعوض
حول اماكن النفايات يقابله احصاء لمنظمه
الصحه العالميه يقول ان مئات الاشخاص
توفوا جراء انتشار الكوليرا في المدينه
عقب اندلاع الحرب نور الحصني العربيه